rolling Back The Years Henry Kissinger's
once again in the Chinese Capital once
again talking to a Chinese leader
would be able to
with China
and it is extraordinarily goodies of you
to arrange the meeting
you've just celebrated your 100th
birthday and I wish you a long and
healthy life it was the most effusive
welcome in China for a U.S figure in
recent years Kissinger being described
as an old friend and significantly
meeting with the defense minister who
sanctioned by the U.S and who recently
refused to meet his U.S counterpart
Lloyd Austin secretary Austin has been
very clear since the beginning of the
administration that the department is
interested in open lines of
communication with the PRC unfortunately
by and large they have not responded to
those requests 52 years ago Richard
Nixon was the president who walked the
halls of The West Wing he instructed
Henry Kissinger to set up a series of
secret meetings with Chinese leaders
these paved the way for Nixon's historic
visit to China in 1972. Kissinger's
visit comes amid the historic low point
in relations between Washington and
Beijing over issues such as Taiwan
technology trade and China's human
rights record
it was a visit that changed the course
of history encouraging a parting in the
sino-russian relationship and heralding
the fall of the Soviet Union nearly two
decades later our strategy was to
position ourselves in such a way that we
were closer to Soviet Union and China
then they were to each other
so that in every crisis
we had more options than they did this
time around perhaps it's China sending a
message to the United States He emphasis
the the Chinese side is placing on on on
the Kissinger visit is to say this is a
choice this is a choice on your side
you're creating the negative conditions
there are Americans that are not just
working in business but in the Strategic
community that we can have good
relations with the somewhat guarded
response from the White House and the
state department Henry Kissinger is a
private citizen no longer speaking for
the United States as he did over half a
century ago
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington